I did read somewhere that uh Jen's Shaw
I guess some paperwork came out that she
was making 34 500 an episode we never
really talk about contracts and money
that's usually just a line that we don't
really love to talk about anyway oh
people are curious Andy's right it's the
question every Bravo fan wants to know
how much does each housewife make per
episode well they now have a better
picture thanks to two veterans I'm the
girl next door if you live in a big old
mansion
without giving too much away there is a
formula from what I've gathered of how
much you get paid per episode per season
Real Housewives of Dallas Alum Stephanie
Hallman speaks out in reaction to a
disgraced snowflake holder the only
thing I'm guilty of is being Sean
amazing of course that didn't turn out
to be true as Jen Shaw is facing a whole
new reality away from Salt Lake City
serving a six and a half year prison
sentence in Texas
how you doing how you doing last year
Jen's bombshell guilty plea in her
federal fraud case rocked the Bravo
verse I honestly thought that she would
fight it to the end in the aftermath
alleged details about how much Bravo
Stars Bank according to documents
released by a lawyer who keeps tabs on
housewives legal cases Jen was making
thirty four thousand and five hundred
dollars per episode in her final season
Flats nuts it's an exciting tidbit as
cast members stayed tight-lipped when
asked about their paychecks their usual
response you gotta asked Bravo but we
should note et's learned that reported
number is not accurate meanwhile
Stephanie was already suspicious telling
fans to take that figure with a grain of
well salt I did read somewhere that uh
Jen's shy got some paperwork came out
that she was making 34 500 an episode I
only have five years of experience but I
will tell you that is over double what
you normally would make season three and
my experience so I will leave you at
that if she was getting paid that she
was getting paid a crazy amount of money
to stay on season three in fact Jensen
baldman in the series all together was a
Hot Topic at The Reunion yeah I don't
know why you would sign up to be a
housewife or running a telemarketing
scheme back in steps breakdown there's a
few other takeaways for the fans I will
say season one for me I felt like I was
paying to be on the show like I
definitely probably spent more than I
made
um season five I was making great money
uh there is I would say season three is
when you kind of start making pretty
good money and that I think is why after
season three you see a lot of housewives
that leave and then they keep a smaller
percentage so uh it's because they get
expensive I mean season five it was very
expensive one thing I can say about the
show is personally and you know with
friendships and marriage you can learn a
lot about yourself and your relationship
and you can really grow from it if you
if you try to learn from it if you don't
just try and make excuses I honestly
love the girls in Salt Lake I have not
watched it
um so I don't know if it was worth the
34 500 uh paycheck each episode but that
is a big big paycheck
[Music]
thank you